SUDHEERA VANGURI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the
Document AI session.
I'm Sudheera Vanguri, and I lead
the language and DocAI product
suite at Google Cloud.
Today, I'm very
glad to be joined
by Nadia, a senior outbound
product manager at Workday.
A quick runthrough
of the agenda today.
I'll provide a brief
overview of Document AI
and how we convert documents
into business-ready structured
data.
We'll then dive into
workplace approach
using DocAI to gain
operational efficiency.
So let's dive right in.
For centuries,
documents have been
foundational to our societies.
We record histories,
establish laws,
legitimize trade, launch
companies, and confirm
identities with documents.
The computer age has
introduced the idea
of digital documents,
which now serve
as a backbone of our
modern societies.
The power and value of
digital documents is immense.
But for all the value that
these documents have created,
digital documents
still require work,
not only in creating them, but
in processing these documents.
Every company today
processes digital documents.
The size and burden will
vary, as will the importance
of those documents.
But no company is able to
escape the reality of what
we call digital manual labor.
If you're watching this
session, you probably
know what I'm talking about, but
let me give you a few examples.
Digital manual labor comprises
the work that many of us
do, but almost never shows
up in a job description.
It is essential to the vast
majority of today's business
workflows, and it
captures the value of data
in those digital documents.
It is also candidly a pain,
validating, checking, sorting,
keying, copy/pasting,
normalizing, et cetera.
And with the continued
growth of digital workflows
and digital
transformation, we expect
this burden to only grow.
For example, as the health
care industry has digitized,
the ratio of health care
administrators to physicians
has grown 35x, representing
the enormous and important work
of ensuring that our health
care records, prescriptions,
pre-authorizations, and
medical bills, all documents,
are processed properly.
So let's talk about how we
want to help our customers
and their employees manage the
toil of digital manual labor.
Document AI represents
Google's investment
to bring the power
of machine learning
to processing documents.
You may have even seen
this slide before.
In fact, we've shown this
slide to hundreds of customers,
and to be honest, sometimes
their reaction is not
very enthusiastic, and
that's because many of them
think that they've already
solved this problem
with other technologies.
Awareness of the pain
for digital manual labor
is not new.
For decades now,
smart people have
been working to
capture structured data
from digital documents.
OCR, key value pair extraction,
template-based readers,
and other technologies
are now commonplace,
even so far that
the term OCR has
become a shorthand for document
extraction more generally.
In short, if you try
digitizing documents,
you probably used one or
more of these or services
that are built on them.
But if you've tried
using those technologies,
you've probably realized that
they aren't the full answer
for most business workflows.
While they do what they say with
increasingly higher accuracy,
they also create new
kinds of digital work.
Pre-processing, post-processing,
rules management,
and template management are
new kinds of toilsome tasks
that now often shift
burden to IT departments.
The reason why these
legacy technologies
require supporting
labor, manual labor,
is because
understanding a document
is much more than
reading a document.
In order to properly
understand a document,
humans do much more than
read words off the page.
They bring knowledge
of what the document is
and what it should contain.
They are able to interpret
different structures and words.
They can connect
what they're reading
to other data in the
workflow or even from Google
to make sense of it, and so on.
It's actually an
incredibly difficult task,
one that is harder to
automate than many expected.
That's why, with
Document AI, we have
made it our goal
to turn documents
into business-ready
structured data.
As we work closely with
our leading customers,
we realize that a
part of the problem
is that legacy
technologies are solving
a problem that is too simple.
Yes, you can get some structured
data with a table parcel,
but we have heard that what
customers are looking for
is business-ready
structured data.
In other words, they're
looking for a technology
that will read documents
in ways similar to humans.
They are looking
for the confidence
that when they start
to automate processes,
they are not signing themselves
up to a different kind
of digital manual work.
When we say business-ready,
what do we mean?
Of course, for each customer
and each business process,
the definition of
business-ready will vary,
but as we have moved
models into production
with more and more customers,
some consistent themes
have emerged.
At a high level,
customers have asked
for an end-to-end
solution that is
business-ready for any
document and business-ready
for any document workflow.
Business-readiness
for any document
means that DocAI can
process a given document
and deliver structured data
that a customer can immediately
trust and use.
We have summarized this as four
C's, consistent and accurate
extraction, complemented with
other data, cross-border-ready,
and corrected as needed.
I will spend the
next few minutes
covering what we mean
by each of these.
But solving the
business problem doesn't
end with understanding
a single document.
That is why we have
three more C's which
speak to the importance of
supporting the entire document
workflow; the ability
to custom build
new processes for a wide range
of new or long-tail documents,
the ability to comprehensively
orchestrate and execute tasks
across the document
workflow, and the ability
to constantly improve models.
I will come back to these
at the very end of our time.
I want to spend some time going
deeper into the first four
C's that we mentioned
about and how
we can get business-ready
data from a DocAI processor.
Again, these are those four C's.
Consistent and
accurate extraction,
complemented with other
data, cross-border-ready,
and corrected as needed.
First, let's look at consistent
and accurate extraction.
One of the wonderful
things about documents
is that they start
as blank slates.
They can take on any
structure or design.
Of course, this is also what
makes them hard to automate.
But for any given
document type, you
may encounter a wide variety
of formats, versions, concepts,
words, et cetera, and
humans are naturally
able to make sense
of these differences,
but machines need
special training.
And that's why we
are investing in what
we call specialized parsers,
machine learning models that
are built specifically for
any given document type.
Here's a sample output from
the Document AI console,
and you'll see that the core
schema, supplier name, supplier
website, invoice ID don't
actually show up as text
on the document anywhere.
Instead, these are concepts that
our models have been trained
over thousands and
thousands of samples
to recognize and then find
from one invoice to the next,
and this can be especially
powerful when there are, say,
multiple addresses which
belong to the supplier
versus the receiver.
Specialized processors can
make these distinctions
that are ultimately
the difference
between business-ready data
and more digital manual labor.
As you may know, we
have begun our journey
with specialized processors
focused on lending
and procurement workflows.
In fact, we are
actively building
towards a library
of parsers for all
the world's most commonly
used business documents.
And today, we are glad to
announce our latest edition
with Contract DocAI, specialized
document processors, what
we call the most valuable
documents on the planet.
For more details, please
check out the AI100 session.
We are also proud to announce
that we are continuing
to expand the lending
DocAI portfolio
and now have about 50
specialized processes
available for use.
And there is much
more in flight,
which we'll be rapidly
releasing over the coming weeks
and months.
OK, onto the next C,
complemented with other data.
This is something we are
especially excited about.
When the information is missing
or ambiguous on a document,
like a missing address
or entity name,
a human often needs to search
for it, often on Google.
With DocAI, we are bringing
the power of Google Search
to help customers
understand their documents.
That means that the
same Google Knowledge
Graph that helps you find
the name or address or phone
number of a restaurant
you want to go to
can enrich your document
extraction with the right name,
address, or phone number.
Here is a sample received from
a colleague's trip to Europe.
If he were filling
out an expense report
and needed to input
merchant name,
he might struggle to choose
between some good options,
Angelina, Angelina
Paris, Angelina Rivoli.
He might, say, take some
time to go to Google
and find the right entity
name, that is, Angelina Paris,
or he might guess and
move on, potentially
creating headaches for the
finance team down the line.
With Document AI,
there is a better way.
Our native integration
with Google Knowledge Graph
means that we can deliver
both the specific text
from the receipt as well as
Google's best understanding
of the actual name of
the restaurant that
operates at this address.
Here's another example,
and in this use case,
the supplier address does not
appear anywhere on the receipt,
and this creates a choice
of either extra work
or potentially incomplete
or inconsistent data.
However, Google
knows that the Office
Depot in Los Gatos
with this phone number
is located at 15166
Los Gatos Boulevard,
so DocAI is able to enrich
this field, which would have
otherwise been returned empty.
We are very proud to announce
that this Google Knowledge
Graph integration is aligned
with many of our core DocAI
processors, from
procurement to lending.
The extraction of information
from invoices to receipts, bank
statements, pay
stubs, and more is now
enriched with the power of
Google's Knowledge Graph,
and we are actively working
to grow this capability out
for all relevant fields
across our entire portfolio
of parsers.
The next C is
cross-border-readiness,
specifically the ability for
companies to process documents
in every language that
they do business in.
Few of our customers do
business in only one country
or language, and their
doc processing workflows
need to scale with them.
And at Google, we have
taken a two-pronged approach
to this problem.
First, we are building
custom specialized processors
for some documents in
high-volume languages,
think Spanish invoices or
French identity documents,
and second, we are
building on Google's
longstanding leadership
in machine translation
by integrating translate
capabilities directly
into our specialized processors.
This means that customers
will get instant access
to specialized doc processing
in hundreds of languages.
Here's an example
of a French invoice.
And again, you'll
see the full benefits
of schematized parsing, as
fields like supplier name,
supplier address are
extracted from the document,
even though the field names
themselves don't show up.
As an aside, I want
to quickly highlight
amount of work that has gone
into the computer vision models
under DocAI.
It's no small feat to be able to
read, say, the supplier address
off a document of this quality.
In addition to our
specially trained models,
our integration with
Google Translate
means that customers can
now process documents
in over 100 languages, all of
those supported by the Google
Cloud translate service.
Critically, while the
specially trained models
are of highest quality,
the translate-based models
have demonstrated
minimal quality losses.
We're also pleased
to announce that many
of these cross-border
investments
are now available to our
customers, specifically
Procurement DocAI.
The Procurement DocAI
team has specially
trained additional models
in six languages, primarily
European ones.
With Procurement
DocAI, we have also
integrated the
translate pipeline
into the invoice
and expense parsers,
expanding support to
100-plus languages.
This feature is in preview
today and is also actively
being rolled out to all relevant
specialized parsers in future.
The fourth and final C for
today is corrected as needed.
This highlights the reality
that for many workflows,
we will always need humans
involved to some degree.
And while we can ease the
burden of digital manual labor,
we still need humans to
be the final reviewers
of critical and challenging
doc processing steps.
Our reviewer interface
brings the intuitiveness
and the simplicity of
Google interface design
into the hands of doc reviewers,
and we display the document
alongside the structure
data extraction,
highlight areas that
need more attention,
enable easy and on-document
corrections, and much more.
DocAI then returns for the
original and updated data
as part of the JSON output.
As customers grow their
doc processing operations,
it is essential that they
are able to definitely manage
the wide range of settings
and priorities and tasks
and resources that
they oversee, and that
is why we have built the
manager interface as a control
panel for all of these needs,
and this is directly integrated
into the DocAI section
on the GCP console.
We are now glad to announce
that the full range
of human-in-the-loop
functionality described below
is now fully available
for Lending DocAI,
expanding the coverage
that already existed with
Procurement DocAI.
We are aiming to make this fully
available for all of our doc
parsers, not only
for extraction,
but also for splitting
and classification.
To recap, here are the summary
of all the new announcements
that we've made today.
With Procurement DocAI, we
have Google Knowledge Graph
integration in GA.
We have custom-trained models
for high volume models in GA.
We have translate
integration in preview.
We have the Lending DocAI
with six new GA parsers
and 30 more in preview.
We have Contract DocAI
now available in preview.
We have Google Knowledge
Graph integration available
on Lending DocAI, and we have
human-in-the-loop integration
also available in GA
for Lending DocAI.
We also have expanded language
support for Procurement DocAI.
For the last 10 minutes, we have
walked through many investments
we're making and improving
document processing workflows,
and we realize that for
our enterprise customers,
these workflows
are almost always
a part of a larger business
workflow; procure to pay,
expense to reimburse,
[INAUDIBLE] qualification,
insurance policy
underwriting, and so on.
And that's why we are proud to
work with [INAUDIBLE] and SaaS
companies that are leaders
in helping customers execute
these business workflows.
One fantastic example of
this is our collaboration
with Workday, who
has been pioneering
the very use of Document AI
to reduce digital manual labor
in daily business workflows.
Today, I'm very
glad to be joined
by Nadia, a senior outbound
product manager at Workday.
Nadia has been a fantastic
collaborator and thought
partner for Document
Ai, and I'm very
excited for you to see
how she and her team
have brought the best of DocAI
into the hands of their users.
I'm glad to introduce
Nadia to tell us
more about their journey.
NADIA AQSA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Nadia Aqsa.
I'm the outbound product
manager for Workday Expenses,
and I'm so excited
to be here today.
In the five years that I've
been with Workday Expenses,
I don't think I've ever
met a customer that has not
asked how we are driving
operational efficiency
through machine learning.
Whether it's OCR or
intelligent insights,
automation is top of mind
for our 1,350-plus Expenses
customers.
Today, I'll be
sharing a little bit
about what we've been
able to accomplish
with the help of DocAI
and more excitingly,
where we are headed next.
But before we go any
further, let me tell you
a little bit about Workday.
Our mission is to deliver
value through our enterprise
management cloud that
brings financial management,
spend management, human
capital management,
and analytics together
in a single cloud.
Our vision for the travel
and expense solution
is to put the
employee at the center
of a touchless
experience by eliminating
manual entry and cumbersome
review and approval processes.
Earlier this year, Workday
combined Google Cloud's
Procurement DocAI solution with
our own document processing
machine learning models to
deliver an elevated experience
for our customers.
These customers can now scan
receipts in five languages
and have the most
pertinent details
auto-populated for them.
With 98% of Workday
Expenses customers
either creating or
editing expenses
on Workday mobile
in the past year,
this update made a lot
of people very happy.
Let's take a quick look at the
receipt scanning in action.
We are in a demo
environment, and we're
going to use expense receipt
scanning service powered
by Google to scan a receipt
for our user, Dagmar,
who is an office
administrator in Germany.
For the sake of
this demo, I have
switched her preferred
language to English.
Dagmar went to a local
print job to copy documents,
and she saved the photo of the
receipt on her mobile device.
She clicks the Scan
Receipt option, which
takes her to her photo album.
From there, she
selects the receipt
that she wants to upload.
The scan process has
kicked off, and it only
takes a few seconds to complete.
Now that the scan is completed,
let's take a closer look.
On the receipt, we see that
the merchant is not mentioned.
We see the merchant address.
We see the date.
We also see the amount
as well as a currency.
Now, let's scroll down further.
The date, amount,
as well as currency
are populated as expected.
And to our surprise, the
Google Knowledge Graph
used the merchant's address
to derive the merchant name.
How cool is that?
That's definitely
going to save her time.
To complete the expense
report submission,
Dagmar will need to
select an expense item.
And I know what you're thinking.
Workday, when will you default
the expense item for her?
Well, that's something that
we're working on right now,
and we hope to
release it very soon.
At this point, Dagmar can go
ahead and select the expense
and add it to her
expense report.
All right.
Hopefully you were
also just as impressed
with the magic of
the Knowledge Graph.
It's going to continue to be
instrumental towards delivering
a differentiated experience
for our customers.
Now, some of you
may be wondering
why this is even a big deal.
I mean, you saw that we
scanned a few fields that
could probably be entered
manually pretty quickly.
And if you're thinking
that way, that's OK.
I've had to explain this before.
So let me use a few numbers
to do the same thing.
In 2019, so pre-COVID
era, our customers
uploaded 27 million expense
receipts into Workday.
If that manual receipt entry on
average takes about 3 minutes,
that is 1.35 million
hours of time
spent doing tedious tasks that
adds no real business value.
And post-COVID,
we actually expect
this number to be even higher.
Also, keep in mind that people
are not hired to do expenses,
and as an expenses PM, I
will be the first to admit
that no one even
enjoys doing expenses.
So in other words,
in this day and age,
no one should have to enter
expense receipts manually
because that time
is better spent
on doing value added work.
I hope this helps
you understand why
we are so excited about
this, and with the help
of the Procurement
DocAI solution,
we expect to save customers
hundreds and thousands of hours
and enable them to get back
to doing their real jobs.
Now I'm going to
talk a little bit
about what's coming up next
for us in relation to DocAI.
By the end of this
year, our customers
will be able to scan receipts
in 100-plus languages.
And although that, itself,
is a giant leap forward,
we are not stopping there.
We're looking at a
number of opportunities
to create a touchless
expense entry experience,
and I want to share a
couple of examples with you.
We will support fields
that are handwritten.
So for example, you
have a meal receipt
that has a tip that's
been handwritten.
We'll be able to scan that and
auto-populate that for the user
so that they don't have to worry
about entering that manually.
In addition, we'll be
scanning additional fields,
such as a record
locator that's often
found on a trip itinerary.
And what that will
help Workday do
is to use that as
a unique identifier
and link that to an existing
credit card transaction that's
already been imported into
Workday to accurately match
the two so that the user does
not have to worry about that.
These enhancements and
many more will further
reduce the burden
of manual entry
and simplify expense
submission for our users.
In addition, I want to mention
that aside from expense
submitters, approvers
and reviewers are also
two key additional
players in the expense
to reimburse process.
Today, many of our customers
painstakingly review expenses
line by line, and they
do this to identify
items that may be out of
policy or incorrectly coded.
With the help of
Procurement DocAI,
Workday will be able to provide
additional intelligent insights
that will help the approver
and reviewer reduce
the time that it takes to
get through that process.
And that, in turn, will reduce
the time to reimbursement
because everyone wants to
get their money ASAP, right?
So how are we going to do this?
Well, the Google
Knowledge Graph will
help us identify the
category that a business
establishment belongs to.
And this information
will help determine
if the expense is reimbursable.
So for example, you
have an employee
that goes to an adult
entertainment club and expenses
that transaction as a meal.
That does happen.
Believe me.
So we will take that
insight about the business
establishment that's provided
by the Google Knowledge Graph,
and we will flag that
expense for the reviewer
so that they are able to
make an informed decision on
whether or not that expense
should be reimbursed.
Another common problem that
approvers and reviewers
run into is ensuring that
the receipt is itemized
so that it satisfies
the requirements
of their back
office audit teams.
With the help of
DocAI, we will plan
to determine if the
receipt is in the format
and has a content that satisfies
a criteria for valid documents.
Now, Workday is also
looking at DocAI
for supplier invoices
and contract scanning
to improve document
understanding
and enable users to make
better decisions more quickly.
Our customers are incredibly
excited for what's to come,
and I want to thank
Sudheera and the DocAI team
for the invaluable work
that they've been doing.
That's it for me.
Now, over to Sudheera.
SUDHEERA VANGURI: Thank
you so much, Nadia.
We couldn't be more excited
about what you are building
and how it will help
people with the work
they're doing every single day.
We spent most of our
time today looking
at how DocAI can
take a given document
and extract the
business-ready structured data
and specifically how this
comes to life with receipts
and expenses at Workday.
Before we go, I want to spend
just a minute on last three
C's.
These are investments
we are making
in DocAI that will ensure that
customers' document workflows
are business-ready as well.
Custom processors
reflect the reality
that many customers
would need process--
will need to process proprietary
or less common documents
in addition to those for which
there are specialized parsers.
And we want to make it
easy for those customers
as well to quickly build
high-value, high-quality
processors that work perfectly
well alongside the rest
of the DocAI processors.
Comprehensiveness
refers to the need
to address more than just the
document extraction and review,
and there are many challenges
upstream and downstream
in the document
workflow, and we want
to help customers
solve those too.
And finally, we
want to make sure
that DocAI is getting
more and more helpful
as you work with it more.
Not only are we committed
to constant improvements
in our underlying
models, but we also
want to allow our customers
to improve upon them
for their specific domains.
Here are a few
highlights of the things
we're working on
related to these areas.
While we didn't
have the time to go
into all of these
exciting details today,
we look forward to
sharing more with you
as we continue our journey
and perhaps at NEXT 2022.
With that, here are
a few ways that you
can learn more and even
get hands-on with DocAi.
And please get in touch with us
via your Google Cloud contacts
or directly at
docai-external@google.com.
Thank you again for
joining us today,
and we look forward
to working with you
all on all of your
document-related challenges.